okay you can discuss politics and the
program and whatever else is of interest
to you with nearly 5,000 other David
Pakman show viewers and listeners on our
subreddit which you can find at david
pakman.com slash read it I was browsing
some of the discussion topics this
morning and a lot of interesting ones I
wanted to share with you any of these
conversations that are interesting to
you go to david pakman.com slash read it
one post saying robert muller for
president what would you say about a
2020 run by robert muller the guy who
hopefully takes down Trump it's a very
interesting idea but no thank you
Robert really needs to keep his head
down do this investigation don't
consider what you were working on
something that would lead to a political
career I think he's in his mid-70s
anyway and I don't think he has any
interest in running for president just
let the guy do the investigation you
know we talked about robert muller
running for president it just plays into
this republican idea that this whole
thing is a witch hunt absolutely even if
he does it afterwards i mean don't do it
bad idea about it fascinating but
terrible idea also on our reddit
discussion forum what is the
significance of Roy Moore's loss a very
interesting discussion about the
implications of the fact that a Democrat
won in the Alabama Senate in the US
Senate from Alabama for the first time
in something like 25 years good
discussion and very timely in light of
the results from Tuesday's special
election also from the reddit discussion
forum trouble calling in a caller asking
is anyone else having trouble getting
their calls connected when David days
calls from listeners we are aware that
sometimes we pick up on someone Pat and
then I say hello hello and we don't hear
anybody we've done a number of different
tests and there is every indication that
our system is working fine we just don't
know what causes it
I don't know the problem sometimes the
callers say that they can hear me and
that they're talking but that we can't
seem to hear them but we've tested it
every way we know how and are not able
to replicate the issue and it happens
maybe one in five calls right not even
yeah roughly like one in six or seven is
not substantial we were unable to route
it out to find it in two routed out so
know what's going on with that and also
from our subreddit happy Chanukah to
David and all who celebrated as you know
I am culturally Jewish but I'm not
religious and I completely forgot about
the start of Chanukah I don't even know
where my menorah is I haven't lit a
single candle I'm just I just am not
aware of I just don't do anything like
that I had to remind you the other day
yeah at Hanukkah head start that's right
I only found out about Hanukkah because
Pat told me about it and I think do we
have one more here yes don't do it don't
destroy the Keurig machine yeah we got a
Keurig machine a used Keurig machine in
the mail from a use of viewer named Matt
who said give it to Pat if you want
destroy it if you want and a lot of
people this is not the only person
saying we shouldn't destroy it but more
about that in today's voicemail segment
join the discussion david pakman.com
slash read it